tout cas depuis le constat fait sur
notre antenne début septembre de la
frigidité de je veux dire de la
frilosité du monde politique quant à la
campagne référendaire le monde politique
en question semble s'être quelque peu
réveillé et les réunions s'activent pour
ou contre la ratification
ce soir nous allons ouvrir le débat avec
confrontation qui organise salle
rabelais à montpellier donc ce soir un
débat sur le thème après le référendum
que se passera-t-il si le oui en porte
ou si le nom l'emportent
vous allez entendre deux des débatteurs
tous deux en délicatesse d'ailleurs avec
leur parti d'abord le socialiste jean
luc mélenchon qui envisagent les deux
cas de figure si le vote est négatif je
crois que tout le monde commence à
comprendre que nous allons dans un
inconnu plein aventure et pas dans les
bonnes conditions car qu'il y ait ou non
le traité de maastricht l'acte unique
s'appliquera et par conséquent nous
aurons la cie libre circulation des
capitaux des marchandises et des hommes
sans aucun contrepoids politique
maastricht c'est le contrepoids
politique à la libre circulation des
capitaux et des marchandises
si le oui donc l'emportent et bien là
aussi nous irons dans un monde nouveau
il faut pas se le cacher et moi je vous
dis comme socialiste qui ne suis pas
totalement satisfait du texte du traité
de maastricht que tout commence tout
reste à faire mais avec des bases
solides et nous aurons une chose
nouvelle
et comme on estime formidable
à pouvoir plus grand du parlement
européen à pouvoir plus grand des
instances démocratiques de la communauté
européenne et donc on commencera enfin à
avoir un début d'europe des citoyens ça
c'est ça la nouvelle frontière